you want to do a prank sure let's do a
prank
all right so do you know have uh did you
discuss with our producers what the
prank would be like what you're thinking
i i didn't i i did receive word that
that you'd like doing pranks and would
like to do something like that on the
air so what
they're saying uh my producers here are
saying here's another idea
you want to call zach holmes and okay
my homeboy zach yeah who's new he's the
newest member of the
jackass crew isn't he i didn't say that
knoxville said it a week ago our daddy
uh okay undercover why are you not
allowed to
talk about it i was under the impression
that we weren't supposed to uh
to talk about that too much but i didn't
say it i don't want to i don't want to
go
i could pull up the clip of knoxville i
mean whatever i like uh as long as he
didn't say it
okay okay but you want to call him and
okay well that's that's the prank right
there
what what dude like uh they leaked to
say to say
because his name was i got a [ __ ]
like we got a breach of contract
situation here so they're they're
gonna they're gonna take them out
they're gonna
take him out of the movie because
because knoxville
uh mentioned it and it was on youtube
and
would it would it would you believe it i
mean dude like what's going on here like
i just heard that i'm sitting at the
studio with the pr department
and they're cutting you out you know and
if he wants to talk
you know what what happened man like how
did the how did it get out there
like uh okay so let me get his do we
have his number
yes i have it in the notes is this the
number right here no that's the same no
that's the same one
seth will give it to us here
what happened you just heard a guy poor
kid yeah
she's so excited that the movie is
coming out
and you guys were sworn to secrecy this
guy's in the movie and don't give away
what he does but apparently this came
from uh
did did uh he johnny actually
where did he say it on what two weeks on
youtube there's a series called
undercover
right and he mentioned four different
people
yeah i believe
so he's already done that yeah because
yeah it was two weeks ago
and is this kid uh is he good in the
movie
he's fantastic would he be really
disappointed to find out that he was cut
out
yeah okay just be kind be kind please
here we go this is zach
the new jackass movie i'm sorry but the
person you called has a voice mailbox
that has not been set up yet
not set up yet goodbye goodbye which got
an attitude
attaboy i don't set up my voicemail
either why
straight to voicemail because [ __ ]
voicemail
really yeah voicemail is like babies
[Laughter]
oh my god oh my god well we tried really
i mean here i'll
[Music]
steve could also plug in his phone here
if you plug it in but it doesn't seem
like he even saw
that you can keep the mic look plug it
in here
is it is that not going into the
microphone yeah it is but then your
voice in that
hey what's up yo dawg what's up dude how
are you
dudes how did it that the people are
talking about you're
in the movie like uh
like everyone's talking about you're in
the movie i'm getting asked about it
like in interviews
oh yeah i know dude like uh
and it's it's it's kind of [ __ ] dude
like uh i don't like i i don't think
knoxville was allowed to say that dude
and now why don't i talk to them you
talked to who
no no not when knoxville said that in
the thing we're allowed to say that
we're in the movie
and we're uh that's not what i'm hearing
dude i'm hearing that like
that it's a big [ __ ] problem dude
and they're like what do you mean jonah
said that we're allowed
[Music]
no way dude are you serious yeah she
literally told me we're allowed to say
we're allowed to paramount that we're
allowed to say we're in the movie
i mean maybe maybe things got tangled up
but the word is now
that like they can't even you know
who sings to you i mean dude i'm
sorry i'm talking to everybody and then
gary paramount i know
i think you're gonna lose your footage
dude
[Music]
what
[Music]
uh i mean dude i think they gotta cut
you out
dude dude shut the [ __ ] up
dude i was about to [ __ ] cry dude
i can't do it
dude
were you crying this is gary from
paramount were you crying
my whole life was just like flashing
before no he's kidding they're not gonna
cut out but what we're doing
is we're gonna take your name off the
poster and we're going back
on that because johnny was not supposed
to say anything he released it two weeks
ago
and uh this is not your fault we know it
but the block is not going to be on the
home video
the block is only he's kidding you they
can't cut out what uh
uh on the feature but we're cutting it
out of all the
other uh incarnations of it
this is howie mandel we were just doing
stuff we're doing stuff
with stevo seth and kyle and my daughter
yeah dude you got really upset did you
get any [ __ ] in your vagina
oh my god dude i uh yeah i love you zach
dude and i was just telling howie how
[ __ ] fantastic you are in the movie
is he allowed to tell me that
i was like freaking the [ __ ] out
that's why we do it i was yeah you were
dude i [ __ ]
i'm so proud of you brother dude you're
the greatest man let's talk soon
okay wow do you want to do uh we need
another person to represent
the spaying and neutering of uh puppies
in puerto rico do you want to do our
next year event
he cried we got a tear yeah is that good
i don't know
oh you made somebody
you